when we say goodbye we can't know if
this is the last time we will ever see
you should never greet someone casually
or say goodbye to someone casually
and that lesson came from that
experience every moment was so rich
every time we saw each other and every
time we said goodbye we made sure was a
good thorough full goodbye that's how
you're supposed to live every day anyway
every time you leave your house could be
the last time
you're supposed to like be in the
richness of your hellos and goodbyes and
thank yous
that kind of presence and that kind of
attention and that kind of recognition
that tomorrow's not promised so i
learned that lesson with my father when
he passed
anybody who hasn't spoken to their
parents or their brother or their
cousin that they had a thing with or
their ex and they don't talk anymore
call them
right
now
don't think you're gonna have a chance
to call them
tomorrow or next week and it's like that
opportunity with my father changed every
relationship
in
my life i've cleaned all of the
relationships in my life to no regret i
do not want someone to be gone and i
wish i had and wish i could have i'm
just i'm not doing that in my life and
you know sometimes we get stuck in these
situations
where we're seeking the approval of
someone for our
self-esteem yes
self-esteem is about yourself
right right
but we start looking to other people for
our self-esteem
and
sometimes we find ourselves
looking in broken mirrors
to get a reflection of ourselves and the
greatest tragedy
is when you look into a broken mirror to
see if you're pretty and you're gonna
let that person tell you about your
inner qualities and the greatest tragedy
is when you look in a broken mirror and
you're gonna change your face to try to
look good in a broken mirror you don't
try to build a wall
you don't set out to build a wall you
don't say i'm going to build the biggest
baddest greatest wall that's ever been
built you don't start there you say i'm
going to lay this brick as perfectly as
a brick can be laid there will not be
one brick on the face of the earth
that's going to be laid better than this
brick that i'm going to lay in this next
10 minutes
and you do that every single day and
soon
and i think psychologically
the advantage that that gives me over a
lot of people that i have been in
competition with in different situations
is
it's difficult to take the first step
when you look how big yeah
the task is the task is never huge to me
it's always
one breath me too
i realized that to have the level of
success that i want to have is difficult
to spread it out and do
multiple things in order to be world
class and i've made a decision i want to
be
world class it takes such a desperate
obsessive focus to excel on the level
that i want to make movies i'm realizing
that in order to move people in that way
in order to touch people in that way you
really gotta focus with all of your
fiber and all of your heart and all your
creativity and so that's where i am with
uh making films right now there was a
real period in my life that i had to
struggle
with
we can win
or i can be nice pick one and
different people
pick different things right
for the type of material world climbing
that i did for a big chunk
of my life
it was military-minded we're going to
get that flag to the top of that hill
and you are going to help or you're not
going to be here right so that's that's
one mindset and then after i got the
flag to the hill
a couple of times and kept getting the
flag to the hill
and realized that
you don't feel good
and you've scorched earth around you
and nobody's really happy and then i
started to have to question
that mindset i had equated winning with
happiness
right it's like we're winning what is
your problem
there's actually no reason to be scared
it only just ruins your day
you don't have to jump and then in that
moment all of a sudden where you should
be terrified is the most blissful
experience of your life and god placed
the best things in life on the other
side of terror on the other side of your
maximum fear are all of the best things
in life
you know
so at the center of bringing any dream
into fruition is self-discipline
you know some something as simple as
food and eating it it's not about your
your body as much as it is about your
mind it's getting command of your mind
to be able to choose actions that are in
your own best interest every day
we are choosing
that's not in our own best interest
right so if the world is attacking you
and the world wants to fight you and the
world's trying to hold you down so you
won't kick yourself in the balls
so you don't stop yourself from getting
what you dream
[Music]
self-discipline is the center of all
material success you cannot win the war
against the world
if you can't win the war against your
own mind greatness is not this
wonderful esoteric elusive
[Music]
god-like
feature that only the
special among us
are will ever taste it's something that
truly exists
in
all of us
sitting with ali sitting with nelson
mandela it's very simple
this is what i believe
and i'm willing to die for it period
it's that simple life is school you're
not getting the promotion you want at
work that's school
figure it out someone in your family is
sick
that's school life is the greatest
teacher there is you just have to be
willing to learn and recognizing that
your pain and your suffering is the
thing that the universe is poking
at so you recognize that's where you're
ignorant
you wouldn't be having those struggles
in those areas if you
had a deep
broad comprehension
of the fundamental realities of those
situations
i've been a really
firm
believer
that first and foremost
you gotta believe
and when you believe and if you believe
in the level of your belief will
determine your ability to bend the
universe
if you don't believe nobody's gonna
believe
what i discovered is how cancerous fear
can be
in experiencing a life like you can't be
happy if you're scared so i'm really
confronting all the things that i've
ever been scared of and i'm just finding
this really exuberant freedom in life
happiness is peace it's not pleasure
and everybody thinks happiness is trying
to get as much pleasure as you can get
there is nothing more agitating to your
mind in extreme pleasure it's like peace
and it's like you just come into that
beautiful state of needlessness where
you realize you really don't need
nothing failure is a massive part of
being able to be
successful you have to get comfortable
with failure you have to actually seek
failure failure is where all of the
lessons are you know when you go to the
gym and you work out you're actually
seeking failure you want to take your
muscles to the point where you get to
failure because that's where the the
adaptation is that's where growth is
successful people fail a lot they fail a
whole lot more than they succeed but
they extract the lessons from the
failure and they use that energy and
they use the wisdom to come around to
the next phase of success you gotta take
a shot you have to live at the edge of
your capabilities you got to live
where you're almost certain you're going
to fail that's the reason for practice
practice is controlled failure you're
getting to your limit getting to your
limit getting to your limit you can't
lift that you can't do that you until
you get to the point that all of a
sudden your body makes the adjustment
and then you can do it failure actually
helps you
to recognize the areas where you need to
evolve so fail early fail often fail
forward
as a child my parents always told me you
could be whatever you want to be you
could do whatever you want to do
and
you know that that office that position
the highest office on the face of the
earth
it was something i heard my parents
saying it but i didn't totally believe
it yet i went out in the world and i
carried myself and i held my head high
and i stood there and i looked people in
their eyes and i talked to people as if
i was deserving of everything that this
planet has to offer
so i just i really want to say to to
children out there and to people who are
watching confucius said one time
he who says he can and he who says he
can't are both usually right
and i want you to keep in your heart
just know that you can know that you can
[Music]